vraiment pleine pandémie ça fait partie
du style de vie d'une des villes les
plus moderne et branchée de l'inde
bangalore déguster une bière artisanale
en bonne compagnie martin bernard
dévoile fièrement ses amis brasseur
canadiens allemands et indiens cette
toute nouvelle création une bière ou
melon d'eau le palais indiens les peaux
très accommodant avec ce qui est très
amer donc le secret ça passe le fruité
sa part ce natif du québec est en
quelque sorte le parrain de la
microbrasserie en inde
il est arrivé à bangalore il ya huit ans
alors qu'il n'y avait qu'une dizaine de
microbrasserie de dakhla depuis le début
de voir aussi que de plus en plus les
gens font la différence entre une bonne
vieille mauvaise bien aussi bangalore la
silicon valley de l'inde compte des
milliers de jeunes riches professionnels
locaux et d'expatriés en quête de
brasserie artisanale en quelques années
à peine la ville est devenue la capitale
asiatique de la bière
on compte aujourd'hui une soixantaine de
microbrasseries dans cette ville de 12
millions d'habitants
malgré les ravages économiques causés
par la pandémie mais les établissements
ne peuvent vendre leurs produits que
pour la consommation sur place ils n'ont
pas l'autorisation d'embouteiller leur
bière ou d'offrir des produits à
emporter
moi je vais faire une bière à la mangue
andré leblanc est originaire du nouveau
brunswick
il a longtemps été brasseur en belgique
avant d'arriver à bangalore il ya cinq
ans il est le grand sage passionnés du
milieu de la bière artisanale indienne
il adore les occasions d'expérimentation
dans ce nouveau marché aux possibilités
infinies
moi je suis très dans l'éducation de la
bière c'est à dire je suis maître
brasseur pas passion donc s'arrêter
j'aime j'aime bien transmettre mon
savoir faire aux autres et en inde
ils sont avides de savoir martin bernard
a financé et mis sur pied le seul
laboratoire indien pour la culture de
levure brassicole il rêve de créer une
souche indienne
moi je voulais comme réussir à faire
plus de sortes de bières de variétés
avoir plus de différence dans mais ça va
andré leblanc et martin bernard ont mis
le projet en chantier mais il s'assure
de trouver du temps pour se rencontrer
chaque semaine une bulle canadiennes
dans un pays complexe on parle la même
langue
donc c'est un peu se retrouver un antre
en famille quoi dans un marché en plein
essor deux canadiens la tête remplie
d'idées pilote la petite révolution de
la bière indienne il sait philippe
leblanc radio canada bangalore